devant agir pour faire en sorte que ça
ne se reproduise jamais plus jamais ces
deux mots stéphane brouillons les a
souvent répété il était à polytechnique
le soir de la tuerie nous avons fait
naître des cds pour survivre quatorze
femmes n'ont pas eu cette chance pour
affronter ces horreurs bon nom de témoin
se réfugie derrière deux idées que je
résumerais ainsi plus jamais est pas
pour rien mais trente ans après
polytechnique la violence faite aux
femmes est encore bien réelle plus
jamais sauf les 605 femmes assassinées
au québec en 1997 et 2015 sauf les
milliers de femmes autochtones disparues
sans faire de bruit plus jamais sauf les
douze femmes tuées par leur conjoint ou
leur ex dans la dernière année une par
mois
comme à toutes les années 118 femmes et
filles ont été assassinés au canada
depuis le début de l'année l'an dernier
le conducteur d'un camion a foncé sur
une folle à toronto
ils visaient des femmes parce qu'ils en
voulaient aux femmes sur les réseaux
sociaux la misogynie est bien présente
la mairesse de montréal peut elle même
témoigner de cette violence
oui je reçois des menaces à ça se
produit dans certains cas on voit
vraiment que c'est des menaces misogyne
cccc du genre faut revenir à l'ordre
c'est les hommes qui doivent décider si
ce nom vous serez au sujet vous serez
tout fusillé là je resterai pas
longtemps c'est évidemment c'est sûr
qu'on peut dire on reçoit un message
comme ça pendant sa un dérangé et on se
dit ça un vrai sens mais à part ça
polytechnique jeudi la police de
montréal a arrêté l'auteur d'un blog
anti féministe qui faisait l'apologie du
tueur de polytechnique
je tiens mené évidemment à sa
comparution aujourd'hui vraiment le chef
d'accusation d'avoir fomenté la haine
envers les femmes c'est depuis trente
ans ne cesse de répéter plus jamais
l'accessibilité aux armes
demain en jeu notre accès à des armes
mortellement dangereuses
extraordinairement puissantes et pas
encore fait les plus faciles que en 1989
puis on n'a pas agi le premier ministre
promet de renforcer le contrôle des
armes à feu et d'interdire le type
d'armes qui a enlevé des vies à
polytechnique
car trente ans après le drame ce type de
carabine était toujours également
accessible ici vincent maisonneuve
radio-canada mourir